[Music]
when you guys were children and maybe
even now whenever you had a weapon
where's your choice
a laser laser laser or anything I did
more what you didn't give another I
wanted a little azer a laser did you
guys use a [ __ ] laser oh yeah for
sure yeah yeah we do laser Laser pew pew
pew pew anything a big powers guy cuz I
grew up watching like Chinese kung fu
films there's almost more of like that
like let's say I wanna hurt Nicky I go
on the floor over there I don't want to
give options Dicky because I'll try to
direct the word the conversation laser
lasers are a [ __ ] thing dude so now
that maybe they test a lathe they're
testing a laser weapon and they say that
now I could destroy an aircraft
mid-flight wash why do we want
oh they got [ __ ] test footage yeah
they'll [ __ ] later me that real yeah or
am i watching CG I don't know man God is
that a drone why can't they have a
better camera just sessional like they
got a laser but not a good camera
they gotta leave it with the shooting on
blackberry its 8-bit the dish it looks
like a Nintendo game yeah that's just
tight I was gonna say for Nintendo I had
the n64 a golden I was only [ __ ] yes I
was a drum they tested a high-energy
laser weapon that destroyed a drone
mid-flight so I was able to follow it in
[ __ ] [ __ ] science fiction the
lightsaber [ __ ] cuz imagine they shot
like a nuke and like you have to send
another missile to stop that alright so
the laser laser now but if you send that
laser doesn't just detonate the nuke or
no or just melts it before detonation
has to go Nicky
oh if a meteor was to head towards
planet Earth
can they shoot the meteor and make it
fit [ __ ] I don't know then they just
make more news nice it goes around the
world like this oh we should create a
force the elia
portal around the earth that plane even
explode I just yeah that's true oh it's
like it bounces off so I was like this
force field is like boom maybe because
maybe it's always the technology that
can make the plane fly there's no
technology the meteor like a magnet like
uh like your cell phone could destroy
that we hit a plane yeah why don't you
turn off my airplane it just makes your
hotel key not work anymore
what's that electromagnetic pulse
yeah so you could shoot that out and
then it misses up all the electronics
yeah yeah damn but this is like [ __ ]
what it's like in the movies where they
can make the satellite just like I'd
like it like super laser from space and
[ __ ] so they've been working on this
since the 60s dude it's crazy I remember
back in the back back back ancient times
right there's this painting of a like a
ship that was using a massive glass as a
way to direct Sun energy to [ __ ] that
was like the og laser is like like like
it was like a magnifying glass mmm when
you burn ants yeah will you burn you're
just [ __ ] directing that [ __ ] and
then you're just hitting like a ship
sail [ __ ] blind the captain like he's
like this do you think that what their
control is real well it is is it yeah
well they're able to produce are you
talking about like how they use it on us
or just that they can I'll talk about
what the coal you seem like melted
glacier to cause a flood yes yes maybe
you know what the the lines chemtrails
shows or like you ever see that footage
of when they say like when there were
those fires but it was like what it's so
weird that there's like this straight
line of where the fires stopped that
should I believe I do what is that one
like when you when the fires happen back
in California last year or two years ago
I can remember at last I was mansions I
remember all the time yeah but yeah one
house would be perfectly fine and then
the house next to it burnt to a crisp
is it cuz they have sprinklers no but
they're saying that there's like yes sir
in ways that yeah they're saying they
like mapped out what they wanted to like
to learn but Bob Weir's [ __ ]
house Rachel she's cool it's like that
great I guess
that is some conspiracy [ __ ] dude yeah
Shane Dawson did a whole conspiracy
thing on it oh really yeah on the fire
not watching his videos oh I should try
what not nothing against them not cool
with them boys docu-series are pretty
good I remember but I just forgot like
checking she's almost great yeah there's
a took a cheese 1 do that
it might've been in the same way yeah
really the same like it seems yeah cuz
he did three right I think it was like
nah she oh no no it wasn't tricky cheese
on your birthday I know my Chuckie
Cheese manager okay Stewart and Chuckie
Cheese as Chucky shut the [ __ ] I swear
to God and then one time one upper one
side he'll drag us here so jealous he
was super sick cuz he got like he
started feeling like queasy in his
helmet threw open the [ __ ] thing that
he so he puked but also he was like he
was like gonna pass out cuz he feels so
sick and he said oh we can you buy as
Chucky but you're not allowed to take
your helmet off in front of the kids
it's like policy yeah yeah I said all
the kids were like they're cool did I
just feel like if you ever go to the
church cheese and put one of those on
it's like the nastiest thing yeah
cuz no I did not like quality all
sanitized yeah they probably all the AC
in there everything yeah Chucky is
probably just like stinks and this is
Jesus on the inside for some reason
always saying how Chucky Cheese Chucky
on stage the robot one was like seven
feet tall and then when Chucky came out
in person he was like five foot annoying
as kid movie critic there was a
continuity hey buddy just eat your peas
in and join us okay cuz I think at a
very young age I already know there was
a human in that [ __ ] but I would
be critical to I'm like can you at least
close that [ __ ] curtain when the when
the bad is done so when somebody comes
out it's like and then there's Chucky
green hat and Chucky purple hat I'm like
what the [ __ ] dude yeah dude it at
disneyland hotel they have the
characters walking around you know and
so you can eat brunch there and like
your autographs from the characters and
it was so weird because weird right when
Aladdin came out and Princess Jasmine
was a person with like she looked like
you know me with [ __ ] hair shed a wig
or whatever but she was a person but
then Jafar was like a mascot is like
what [ __ ] head on cartoon
it's always like well Jafar's fake
Jasmine's real I'm getting her autograph
and then [ __ ] Jasmine goes oh my god
oh well it's too much Sam I remember
having a little bit of butterflies and
anxiety with the goofy meet-and-greet
cuz you tell cuz you're such a fan or
what yeah like Gil's my first celebrity
dude like when toontown opened up I was
waiting in lines like 14 and all right
no let me say something that's actually
not too weird because my ex loved Mickey
Mouse like loved making mouth like said
she had a crush on I'm all this she
wanted to smash Mickey Mouse ears during
oh she would drink Mickey well we went
to his house could you go to his house
in toontown oh yeah
and literally he came out and she
started to get like she got flustered
like her face got red it's [ __ ] Jorge
in there don't you know that what do you
do if you went to his house and like her
Wi-Fi automatically connected and like
she gives birth to our child and he has
gloves
no that was my first celebrity man and I
was like my heart was pumping and all
like I can't believe I'm gonna oh I'm
gonna tell him I'm his biggest fan I'd
like how to rehearse what I'm gonna say
I was like [ __ ] we took a picture I got
his autograph
is there anyone like that for you now
nah cuz mangle was off like James K
Dwight Michael James Keith why I'm
trying to be as friend dude but you
gotta help him out [ __ ] maybe Dave
Chappelle really yeah I think so maybe
Dave Chappelle I wouldn't freak out
though me neither
I feel like he's too like real he's not
a god to me like I get back you darling
when they're like a god yeah I like
goofy
I mean I obviously feel social media I
don't feel like that anymore because I
see everyone yeah there is no God
anymore everyone that was profound not
like that baby to idolize the celebrity
way about Eminem but I don't feel like
because it's he's a god I feel like we
sent social media he's not on social
media it's he's done what the only
manager meant that does all the [ __ ] but
um like I think it's more that he's been
in the majority of my life like he voice
has been in my ear since I was 12 and
that's like two-thirds of my life so I I
feel like it's this person that has
influenced me so much that I've never
met in person
mm-hm and yeah I don't think I could
talk to him I think I would [ __ ] myself
I would [ __ ] be like every fluid just
like tears who for some reason I feel
like I'm kind of like you know like when
someone's not that popular anymore you
don't really like them anymore so then
it was just infatuation and you didn't
really like them that's I feel about
presidents so people will be like oh I
can't wait to meet Obama and I'm like
why he's not even president anymore well
Obama was like low-key like just like a
celebrity president though you know yeah
but it went I want to meet him in the
White House when he's president and now
I'm just like ah yesterday's news yeah
you pick Trump over Obama then cuz he's
the current clip if Trump doesn't get
reelected and someone knows I'm like
Trump's wrong next president I think I'd
be pretty hype to like kick it with not
President Obama because I feel like he'd
be so much more chill and we could have
a beer
we didn't sure yeah yeah president he
could make like dirty jokes when like
normal everyone video out so I thought
you do that no matter what yeah yeah
maybe I want to ask Bill Clinton I want
to be like so how many girls are you
real
I heard how are you quite the player
counting Epstein's island or just within
the way house is that new documented I
just came on yeah
well the Navy has a laser and steam
didn't kill himself
[Music]
[Music]